de nombreuses entreprises semblent
vouloir associer des confinement et med
in france objectifs affichés sécuriser
les approvisionnements et faire un geste
pour la planète en réduisant les
émissions de co2 selon une étude agile
billère conseil national d achat réalisé
pour le journal des échos un quart des
entreprises auraient décidé de
relocaliser leurs achats en france après
elle a créé sanitaires on va justement
en parler avec jean marc sylvestre
journaliste éditorialiste économique
jean marc sylvestre bonjour si les
français sont impatients de revenir à
une vie normale les entreprises qui se
remettent en route s'inquiète des
changements qu'elles vont devoir
accepter beaucoup de sondages et
d'études montrent que ces entreprises
françaises elles veulent plus de made in
france
elle cherche à réduire la facture co2
est-ce qu'on pour les entreprises
finalement ce monde d'après sera
fondamentalement différent du monde
avant oui à écouter il ya effectivement
beaucoup de scénarios qui promettent un
monde très différent avec l'idée que ce
qu vite 19 serait un produit finalement
de la mondialisation du capitalisme
financier et même du réchauffement
climatique alors par conséquent tous ces
scénarios prescrivent un changement de
système moins d'avions moins de
communication moins d'argent il ya
surtout beaucoup de politiques la porte
des entreprises est surpassé paniqué par
ses perspectives
elle ne croit pas à des grands
bouleversements cela dit la seule prise
en compte des normes sanitaires va
forcément les obliger à changer la
distanciation sociale par exemple eh
bien elle va elle va toucher la
restauration les trains les avions tous
savons tous c'est sous ces entreprises
vont être obligés par exemple de réduire
quasiment de moitié leur clientèle d'eau
si les activités veulent tenir il va
falloir qu'elles réduisent leurs coûts
de fabrication ou alors qu'elles
augmentent leurs prix mais si elles
augmentent leurs prix
eh bien les consommateurs ne seront pas
là il ya beaucoup d'entreprises qui vont
être obligés de fermer on peut
s'attendre à une hécatombe cela à la
rentrée de septembre avec des faillites
avec du chômage
jean-marc on constate aussi que beaucoup
d'entreprises le plus drôle localisation
et moins de carbone si oui alors
absolument sont les tendances lourdes ça
mais elle existait avant alors la
pandémie va peut-être
c'est l'airé les changements la pandémie
crée une opportunité pour le changement
en gros le premier type de changement
vous le disiez c'est le made in france
25% des entreprises environ vont
relocaliser en france ou en europe des
fabrications qu'elle avait externalisé
dans les pays à faible coût de main de
la crise du coronavirus leur a montré
leur extrême dépendance à l'égard de
l'étranger sont trouvés piégés
l'objectif va donc être de sécuriser les
approvisionnements en diversifiant les
fournisseurs on a vu la sphère de la
sphère des masques par exemple mais il
ya beaucoup d'autres exemples qui
prouvent que les entreprises sont très
dépendantes dans l'ue et pas seulement
dans les produits stratégiques dans
l'automobile dans le textile dans le
bâtiment les industries sont retrouvés
bloqués parce que un seul fournisseur
elle avait un seul fournisseur et il
était lui-même bloqué sur la vie d'anne
les relocalisation dans l'hexagone a
faut pas rêver ça va renchérir le prix
des produits finale parce que les coûts
de production sont plus élevés alors est
ce que finalement ces changements ils
sont gérables et si oui à quelles
conditions
oui alors sur gérable parce qu'il va
falloir accepter les augmentations de
prix
la relocalisation puis la transition
écologique tout ça va coûter de l'argent
qui va payer
qui va payer par le consommateur le
client et vous savez si on a beaucoup
acheté chinois c'est parce que les
usines chinoises sont quand même les
moins chers du monde
donc il faut pas raconter de bêtises il
ya une chose qui inquiète la majorité
des chefs d'entreprise c'est le risque
de décroissance parce que vous avez des
modèles des courants idéologiques ou
politiques des écologistes qui défendent
l'idée de produire moins pour vivre
mieux mais c'est quand même une utopie
quelque part parce que on a besoin de
croissance pour financer le progrès je
suis pas sûr que dans les sociétés de
développer on accepterait d'abandonner
par exemple de digital le smartphone
l'internet ou même tous les progrès de
la médecine on l'a vu avec cette
pandémie un seul exemple vous avez
aujourd'hui
enfin 20 à 30% des français qui jusqu'à
maintenant refusé les vaccins comme la
rougeole le bcg aurait très méfiant par
rapport à tout ça et bien ces mêmes
français aujourd'hui sont prêts à
manifester et pleurer avec des soignants
pour obtenir des traitements et même des
vaccins contre le colis merci beaucoup à
jean marc à
estre je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialiste économique à très bientôt
sur arte france merci